[Music]
today i'm going to show you how you can
manually emulate film look with an easy
step-by-step tutorial without any kind
of luts
and how to approach color grading no
matter if you're working with 16-bit
10-bit or 8-bit footage in this tutorial
i'm going to work in davinci resolve but
you can apply the techniques i'll be
showing you in premiere pro final cut or
pretty much any other software so let's
get into it as you can see i have a
couple clips for my last video called
sony film simulations i'll put a link in
the upright corner if you want to watch
it this is my most popular video so i
thought i'm going to show you what is
most important when color grading and
white 8-bit footage will be enough for
most people i like to manually grade my
footage so i won't be using any color
space transform or a lot in davinci
resolve go to the color page by clicking
on it or by pressing the hotkey shift 6
to travel directly to that page
select the desired clip and press the
hotkey alt s
this will create additional nodes
notes are just like let's say layers in
photoshop i usually rename the node so i
know exactly what i'm working with and
what modifications i have brought to
each node renaming nodes has no hotkey
by default in davinci resolve so i have
assigned this function to the
combination shift r
[Music]
i'll just name all nodes usually i have
between two to six nodes for fairly
simple color grades
first one is temperature even though
first of all i like to work on exposure
and conscious note because i noticed
that applying temperature adjustments to
the second node will give you a worse
color rendition than applying it to the
first one the first one will be
temperature
second one will be basic correction
which is contrast and exposure
uh third will be saturation
fourth will be color grade fifth will be
reflection and the final one the sixth
one will be the film grain you can
download the note 3 from my website to
save a little bit of time and work
together with me in this tutorial link
in description down below
so even though the first note is the
temperature one the first thing i like
to work on is the contrast and exposure
because it's important to see exactly
what you're working with before
everything else
in the second node go to the custom
curve panel and in the top right corner
press the three dots at the bottom of
the list you will find the editable
splines option let's activate it
now let's create a curve
film in general is known to have softer
gradations between tones with soft
clipping shadows and highlights creating
a very moody atmosphere and that's
exactly what we're going to do
usually i like to start by doing an s
curve the idea is to make the image look
soft so be gentle with the curved
splines
so you can understand exactly what we're
doing here the more you lift the spline
the brighter the image the more you
lower it the more details will be hidden
in the shadows so basically you have to
decide which area of the image you want
to show and which don't
practice and in time you will develop a
feeling to where to set the black and
the white point
okay next adjust the soft recovery of
shadows and highlights to recovery
details and for a softer film look
i usually like to bring the shadows up
to around 40 and the highlights to 50 or
even higher
contrast is the base of color grading
remember this so before color there is
contrast that's also a reason why light
is king cinematography and a scene that
is well lit will have more dimension
will be more immersive and overall will
just look better
that's why contrast in color grading is
very important and is the first step in
my workflow
now that we corrected exposure and the
contrast we can start with the color
grading
you know the whole point of color is to
give you a certain feeling a mood and
atmosphere
from here you need to analyze the whole
image and assess what direction you want
to go how do you want the audience to
feel like does it work with the whole
ambience of the clip let's say we can
make a super basic teal and orange kind
of look and i'll show you exactly how to
do that
go to hue vs hue and start looking at
the colors present in the scene we're
trying to simplify the full range of
colors to only two main ones so we will
shift and drag hues to balance out
colors
first step
shift red towards orange and yellow
towards red to make it look even
this way you already made the worm tones
look like a single color with more
creamy transitions and the work is fifty
percent done
okay cool so now let's fix the other
part let's go to the cold tones and
let's shift cyan towards blue blue tour
cyan and magenta towards blue
of course you have to be careful and
pixel p to make sure the colors are not
falling apart
i've seen red cinema camera 16 bit raw
footage falling apart and clearly it
wasn't because the lack of information
in the footage it was just bad color
grading
everything i create for youtube is a bit
which only proves further my point which
is that most people don't need better
cameras they only need to learn how to
manage color if you want to find out
more about color grading i have an
online course which will help you
understand color grading easily and in a
short period of time it's a group class
which i'll be holding next month in this
course i will guide you in the process
of color grading your own footage and
explain different techniques that will
make the whole process easier to grasp
all the luts will be provided at the end
of the course for free so go check it
out link in description
and hurry up there are limited seats
available so back to the color grading
tutorial let's zoom in and check if
everything is okay in the color
transitions so far your footage should
be okay we haven't used any stream
adjustments just yet so most 8-bit
footage should look just fine if you
have 10-bit or 16-bit even better if not
then maybe you have pushed the slider
too far or made too many splines on the
color wave try reducing them to as few
as possible and make subtle adjustments
between colors
last step maybe add a little bit of teal
in the shadows and that's it
this is a super simple way of getting
the teal and orange look without using
the qualifier why use the qualifier if
you don't need it in most cases it will
only create more complications and i'll
talk more about this in the online
course so
now that i've shown you how to make a
teal and orange film look let me explain
why it doesn't fold well on this certain
clip
color grading is a language and needs
motivation which means there must be a
reason why i've chosen specific colors
it needs to be in direct relation
between the model the location the
message or the purpose of the video
putting a teal and orange lut on every
video that you create for your client
might look nice but will have less
effect on the audience because it's not
empowering the message of the clip so
what i suggest you to do is first
analyze the whole image scroll through
the video a couple times or watch the
whole video montage that you plan on
color grading just to get the feel of it
look at the model the surroundings the
weather conditions everything is like a
piece of a puzzle that should fit nicely
together
in this clip the model is alone between
some old ugly blocks with an overcast
sky
it gives me a lonely nostalgic feeling
and i definitely want the colors to
represent that so let's start with a
clean plate reset each node and i will
start by going in the temperature node
and changing the tint hue towards green
making it look more ghetto or dirty in a
way not necessarily trying to make it
look welcoming you know
[Music]
and let's apply the techniques i showed
you earlier for the teal and orange look
i'm going to work towards a trichomatic
color scheme for this image and colors
and the colors will be green orange and
blue so first up
let's correct skin tones because they
look too green right now
so i'm going to shift yellow towards red
and red towards orange to even them out
next step shift magenta stores blue and
that's it
[Music]
let's exaggerate the saturation level to
see if any flaws have been made for
example if any colors are falling apart
or if i shifted too much any of the
colors
then back down the saturation to the
desired level and let's move on to the
halation and film grain davinci resolve
has a halation plug-in by default and
i'll show you my settings
personally i'm a halition junkie so i
usually like it to bleed a lot through
the image if you like it more subtle try
the second settings and adjust the
second glow slider accordingly
last step is film grain i played a lot
with these adjustments and i think i
found the perfect film grain settings
which i'll be sharing with you
[Music]
let's check the before and after
i think it looks great this is exactly
how i edited my shots for the sony film
simulation video don't forget to check
that out the colors are blending
perfectly with the mood and the
intention of the clip this is the
easiest workflow for color grading film
emulation or any kind of look really so
if this works with 8-bit footage believe
me it will definitely work with any kind
of footage so hit the like button
subscribe for more color grading
tutorials and don't forget about the
online course that is coming sign up to
save your spot till next time take care
and have fun see ya
[Music]